[موسيقى]
في شوارع ماليزيا المزدحمه ربما تشاهد
واحده من هذه العربات الكلاسيكيه
والسياحيه التي اصبحت على حافه الاندثار
انها عربه القديمه بالوانها واشكالها
المختلفه
الريكشا عربه ذات عجلتين او ثلاث عجلات
يقودها شخص واحد وتحمل على الاغلب راكبا
واحدا كان الاستخدام الاول لها عام
1879 وهناك العديد من الروايات حول
مخترعها
روايه تقول انها اخترعت في اليابان عام
1869 بواسطه رجل يدعى ايزومي يوسوكي
واستوحى فكرتها من العربات التي تجرها
الخيول وروايه اخرى تقول ان كاهنا في
اليابان اخترعها لنقل زوجته المريضه عبر
شوارع يوكوهاما وهناك العديد من الروايات
الاخرى لكنها في النهايه ظلت في شوارع
ماليزيا وغيرها من الدول الاسيويه حتى
اليوم
اشتقت كلمه ريتشا من اللغه اليابانيه
وتعني المركبه التي تعمل بالطاقه البشريه
هنا في ورشه ماليزيه ريفيه مليئه بالرفوف
من الاطارات في جزيره بينانج شمال العاصمه
الماليزيه
عمرها حوالي 200
حرفي مخضرم منذ شعر ابيض ينحدر من عائله
تخصصت في صناعه هذه العربات يتفقد عربته
التي اوشكت على الانتهاء
من النيون
تعتمد على العمل اليدوي بشكل كبير وتستغرق
العربه الواحده نحو سته اسابيع لتكتمل
ويطرح تشون ثلاثا الى اربع قطع منها سنويا
ويبيع الواحده منها مقابل 1700 دولار
[موسيقى]
باعوامه السته والستين يمثل الجيل الرابع
من عائلته التي توارثت صناعه الريتشا لنحو
100 عام لكن حرفه صناعه هذه العربه بدات
بالتراجع فشعبيتها قلت بشكل كبير مع
انتشار انظمه النقل الحديثه وتراجع الطلب
عليها واصبحت تستخدم بشكل اكبر كمقتنيات
للزينه في المنازل لذلك لم يحرص تشون على
تعليم اولاده هذه الحرفه
شاركونا ارائكم هل شاهدتم مثل هذه العربه
سابقا
[موسيقى]